Mark: Alright you wanna do--
you wanna do blood and gold?
Bob: Sure.
Ethan: Yeah.
Mark: Alright, I'll put bots in this time.
Th-- In this one,
Two random people will be the sharks,
and then four divers.
OH, I am a shark guys
Bob: Yay!!
Bob: The two people who are best at the sharks!
Mark: Yeah :D
Alright!
Ooh, what should I be?
Bob, what are you gonna be?
Bob: Uh, I like the Mako or the Tiger usually.
Mark: I'm gonna go for the Great White,
just for scaring...
Bob: Yeah, you be the, uh, aggressor
and I will be your little companion
who ducks in and out and fucks with them
Mark: Cool...
Gotcha.
Wade: All signs point to us losing badly.
So I have faith
Ethan: Yeah,
Ethan: I'm ready to get eaten alive..
Mark: Hey,
Ethan: I've accepted my fate.
Mark: You've got hard bots on your side
Wade: Oh we have hard bots? Never mind, we won.
Mark: You got hard bots.
Wade: The bots in this game are absurd.
Mark: Are they?
Wade: You've never fought against a hard bot shark?
Mark: Oh, no.
Ethan: Oh no
Wade: Just you wait
Buckle up and prepare to lose.
*Everyone laughing*
Wade: I still have nightmares
and I've not played this game in years.
*Mark laughing*
Bob: Oh, fuck
Wade:These bots are already like,
aiming at you guys.
Bob: No they're not.
Wade: Oh you think they're not.
Bob: Hey buddy :)
How's it going, friend?
Mark: Heyyy buddy
Bob: The one thing that's tough about this
is that I don't really know these maps anymore,
so, as the shark, its hard to
exploit off the little side allies and stuff,
if you don't know the maps very well.
Wade: I don't know the--
I never knew the maps, I never played this game enough
Ethan: Oh :o
There's a flare.
Mark: Wuh--
*Wade sounds of frustration*
Ethan: Oh there're sharks in here already
Hey guys! How ya doing?
Wade: Well, I guess the bots are more obsessed with treasure
than helping their own buddy out. :/
Ethan: Jeeeeez, okay.
Okay.
Oh I got him :)
Mark, that was you.
How does it feel to be DEAD?
Mark: Ha, your friend's dead.
Bob: Oh, he died?
Mark: Ye-yeah, y'know
like a loser
I felt like it--
Bob: Oh, shit snackz
Mark: I felt like dying, y'know
Just-- I didn't wanna give him like,
too much of a scare.
I'm a pretty spooky shark when ya get to know me.
Like right about..
NOW
Wade: OH COME ON! WHY ME AGAIN?!
Ethan: OKAY. OKAY.
*Mark laughing*
Wade: Ethan, can you kill him a second earlier?
Ethan: Well, sorry!
I was trying to repair S.T.E.V.E.!
He's wounded. He needs some--
Wade: He's fine! S.T.E.V.E IS A ROBOT!
I'm a living person!
Ethan: Yeah, well--
Why should I value your life over S.T.E.V.E.'s here?
He's done a lot- FOR US!!
JESUS CHRIST! I'M DYING!
*Everyone laughing*
Ethan: Wade! Why didn't you help me out?!
Wade: I'm sorry, I was busy getting eaten!
*Mark laughing*
Ethan: Ohh, its okay S.T.E.V.E.
I'm here for you.
Don't worry about it.
Bob: Oh you're with S.T.E.V.E., are you?
Ethan: Uh noo
Mark: S.T.E.V.E., huh?
Bob: Oh, that's interesting;
that you're with S.T.E.V.E.
Ethan: I was collecting so much treasure :D
Ohh :o
Hey..
How's it goin'?
Bob: Ah, shit
Ethan: Oh you're dead.
Mark: Alright. Bob, let's-- let's coordinate?
Bob: Alright
Mark: I'll come in,
like a juggernaut,
and then you'll-- you'll smack him upside... the friggin' head.
Bob: Alright, I see you.
I feel you.
Mark: You feel me? You feel me, bruh?
Bob: I feel you bro.
Mark: You feel me?
Ethan: Just in the open ocean..
Bob: I sincerely do.
Mark: Uh oh
Ethan: ...all by myself.
Bob: Oh dear.
Ethan: ...in this room now ._.
Bob: horrible things seem to be happening near you
Ethan: Oh no! Oh no...! Oh no...
Mark: You all alone?
*Ethan sounds of surprise, struggle, and regret*
Ethan: Yeah-- Yeah, I'm dead.
I'm gone.
Ethan: Okay.
Mark: Ow :/
Ethan: They're uh-- they're comin' for ya, Wade.
Bob: Oh my God :o
Jeez.
Mark: That bot-- that bot is good.
Wade: I told ya; beware of the bots.
Bob: That bot is ridiculous..!
Wade: Maybe you guys should go eat something else
and leave the people alone.
Ethan: Yeah.
Mark: Maybe you guys should shut up and just be ready for death. :)
Bob: I could-- I could go eat something else.
Mark: Yeah, I could eat something else.
Ethan: People aren't food for sharks!
Bob: I could fuck a dog
Ethan: ..go eat some seals or some fish
Wade: What?
Bob: What?
Wade: You could, uh, what?
Bob: Nothin'.
Ethan: Huh?
Okay
Wade: Oh-ho-ho-ho
They're screwin' with us!
Ethan: Oh no...
Bob: Who's screwing with you?
I don't anyone's screwing with you..
Ethan: Don't worry Wade, we're gonna be fine.
We're gonna be juuust fine.
'Kay?
Deep breaths :)
Wade: Yeah.
Wade: I mean you're gonna die but I'll be fine :)
Ethan: Deep breaths under (:o) wAaAa-- okay.
oOH! NO WE'RE NOT GONNA BE FINE!
*Mark laughing*
Ethan: I'm being eaten alive!!
*Everyone laughing*
Mark (mocking): Were gonna be just FIIINNNEEE
Bob: Hey buddy.
Bob: Oh no :O
These fucking bots, man.
Mark: Yeah, they're good.
Ethan: Wade, new plan.
We're gonna take the shark corpse
and we're gonna drag it along with us
as a warning sign.
Okay?
Wade: Alright.
Ethan: Alright?
I'm--I'm pushing it along.
Wade: AHH! WHAT THE--
Ethan: Hey, see this?!
This is your shark friend!
That got eaten--er--shot!
Killed.
Now we're gonna eat him later >:D
Ethan: Heh heh heh :D
I'm having a fun time :)
Wade: Welp, hope you're okay, S.T.E.V.E.
Ethan: Heh
I'm having a fun time just pushing this shark corpse along.
Wade: Woah-- WOAH! HEY!
There you are!
Mark: He-hey! :D
Wade: I was wondering where you be.
Mark: "Where I be"?
Ethan: "Where I beee" .___.
Ethan: OoOhh ee~
Bob: Hey buddy!
Mark: Oh! Automated turret
Mark: Holy shit...!
Bob: No~ D:
*high pitched* Fucking bots!
Bob: I don't understand (x4)
Mark: I don't get it guys.
Mark: I don't understand.
Bob: Hey guys.
Mark: You in here?
Bob: How's it going, fellers?
Ethan: Uh--oh...
Okay...
*Everyone's personal sounds*
Ethan: That is vicious.
*cue evil laughter from mark*
Ethan: See you just go though the water and thrash that body around.
Bob: C'mon D:
Ethan: See you just go though the water and thrash that body around
Wade (in his own world): Woohoo
Bob: Oh, Wade actually killed me.
For once, it wasn't your bots just carrying you.
*Mark laughter*
Wade: Wow!
Ethan: Hey! 'Scuse me
Mark: Yeahhhh~
Mark: That's what I'm talking about.
Wade: Hey listen, I've done a lot of damage,
they just always take the credit for my kills.
Wade: Yeah right.
Ethan: I've killed a shark or two in my day :D
Bob: Sorry, we're winning this war of attrition.
Its no big deal.
Wade: That's true.
You are winning that.
*Ethan's quiet sounds of worry*
Mark: 'Kay, I'm gonna--
Bob: Hey guys
Mark: --I'm gonna go in, I'm gonna go in
Bob, I'm going in.
Bob: Alright
Ethan: Oh where are you?
Wade: Oh, come on!
Ethan: Oh~ :/
Where are you? ://
Wade: Poopy!
Mark: ♫ where are you? ♫
Wade: It was eating me right next to
Ethan: ♫ I'm so sorry ♫
*Mark laughing*
Mark: If you just wanted to know..
Ethan: *scared* ♫ where are you? ♫
♫ I'm so sorry ♫
*evil laughter from mark*
Ethan: ♫ I cannot sleeep ♫
♫ I cannot dream.. to-- ♫ --NIIGHTT!
NO-HO-HO-HO
MARK: HAHHAHA
*laughing*
Ethan: I can't dream tonight cuz I'm fucking dead!
Oh no...
Bob: Welp, that's fair.
Mark: Ahh, I almost had 'em.
Bob: Who wants to be my friend~? :)
Ethan: I don't :D
I'll pass
Wade: Oh com-- Help me!!
Ethan: I'm trying my best!
Mark: Awh, dammit!
Mark: Man, I-
Ethan: I can't-- AAHHHH
Mark: I need to seize my arm more,
Ethan: AAAHHHH! NO
Mark: because I'm not able to thrash people dead.
Bob: Yeah you need to seizure harder man.
You gotta thrash the fuck outta them.
Mark: I'm gonna, I'm gonna thrash the fuck outta them
right about... noW! :D
Woah, I missed! D:
Never mind!
*Mark's grunts of effort*
God, I'm thrashing so hard!
Ethan: I feel like I'm killing all the sharks, Wade.
I can't carry the team!
*Everyone laughing at Ethan's pain*
Wade: We noticed
Look at the score
Bob (mocking): "I can't carry the team" :D
I feel like Ethan has some pretty strong opinions about
how your contributions are going, Wade.
Ethan: Yeah, Wade.
*ethan's sounds of despair*
Mark: Jesus.
Wade: Just 'cause I don't get the final hit on half of these things
doesn't mean I'm not helpin' >:|
Mark: Yeah, I like-- Yeah, keep it up,
Yeah, uh, Ethan, what else has Wade done
to wrong you in this department?
Ethan: Yea-- AAAHHHHHH
HAHAHAHAH
Bob: God dammit
Ethan: OH GOD
Bob: I fucking missed Wade
and went and got stupid Ethan >:(
Mark: Hey, I got two!
Bob: Nice
Ethan: I appreciate you finishing me off
because I was just like a half-dead body
swimming in the water.
Bob: You should come hang out with me
Mark: Yeah, you guys should go get treasureee~
Ethan: Treasureeee :)
Mark: Treasure, treasure, treasure
Bob: Yeah
Bob: Collect all the trea-see-yer
Wade: Ahhh~!
Ethan: Oh, there he is!
Wow, you're f-- you're FAST!!
OW!! D:<
God damn...
Bob: Hahahaha
Ethan: [british accent] I can't keep up with ya!
Mark: [too in a british accent] we're a little quick, aint we! :D
Ethan: You're a quick swimmers!
Mark: We are fast :D
Bob: Ah, fucking seals, would you come here?
Wade: Hey, at one point in life
we were the fastest swimmers.
Ethan: Hahahaha~
Yeah!
Its a sperm joke
Wade: *weird noise*
Mark: Heh heh heh heh
Thanks
Thank you for clarifying my own joke for me
Bob: Nailed it
Ethan: Just wanted to make sure everyone was aware :)
Bob: Where are you bitches be at right now?
Mark: We gotta be careful
We're ahead but,
ooh yeah, ooh yeah
Bob: I missed, I missed, I missed
Mark: I got 'em
Wade: HELP
Wade: Welp, okay
I was already, basically dead
Bob: Yeah you were pretty dead
Mark: Ah, fuck
Lotta good those guns are doing you
with your bots around, huh?
Ethan: Yeah they're... doin'... good.
Mark: How are they?
Used? Not really, huh? :)
Ethan: I've-- I've-- I've shot >:o
Mark (mocking): "I've- I've shaht!"
Bob: Hey, I shat at you
Ethan: I shat a few times in my life >:/
Mark: Alright, just be careful, Bob
Be careful, be wise, be wise
Bob: That's not wise, I change my mind
Mark: Word to the wise
Bob: This is unwise
ethan: oh ~ D:
*intense focus* ethan: uh hello?
mark: where are youuu~
Ethan: Ooh! There you are!
Everyone: Hahahaha
Ethan: Okay! Hi!
Mark: That worked. That worked.
That was good, Bob. That was good.
bob: The double distraction?
Mark: Yeah-ha-ha-ha
Once they were looking away,
it was much easier
Bob: Where ya at, bitches?
Mark: Yeah, where you guys at?
Bob: Where ya at bitch-bagz? B)
Ethan: Uh, Being out in the open water--
OHHH-KAY
Mark and Bob: Hahahahaa
Mark: Being out in the open was a bad idea
*Ethan laughing*
Ethan: It was like,
oh, fucking scary
Bob: God dammit
Bob: I can't fucking hit anything, I suck!
I suck so hard
Ethan (mocking): "Sahck!"
Bob: I fahckin sahck cahck!
Mark: I sahck! I sahck cahck!
Wade: Its okay, Bob
Ethan: I sahck cahck...!
Wade: We know..
Bob: Mark is carrying me
Its okay.
Mark: No, its cool
Bob, you're doing great
You just gotta believe in the heart of the you :)
Ethan: I found a totem :D
Bob: I believe in the heart of my boob
Ethan about his totem: Oh yeah! :DDD
Mark: Ye-yeah, thats it, yeah, thats it
Bob: No, nothing's happening, it's fine
Mark: Yeah, nothing's happening
Wade: Yeah, I think were fine
I don't know what you're talking about
Bob: No one is breaking anything,
so, don't worry.
Ethan: I'm not so sure
Bob: Just continue doing whatever
it is that you were doing currently, and its fine.
Ethan: Oh, I've got a plaaAAANNN
I don't have a plan!
That plan was not working
Bob: What?!
Bob: WHAT?!
"What," I say?
Mark: Ahhh! Yes!!
Ethan: Ahh >:o
Mark: Oh shIT
God dammit
Bob: Ha-hah!
Ethan: Fuck, fuck, fuck! Where did he go?
Mark: Ah :/ Get 'em
Get 'em, get 'em, Bob
They're outta tickets, they're outta tickets
We gotta go, go, go!
Go, go get 'em! (x100)
*mark saying get 'em over and over. everyone's got their own noises.* Bob: I'ma goin' !
*Mark sounds of defeat*
Bob: God dammit!
Ethan: WE WON! :D
Bob: I spawn so far away! D:
*Ethan being happy :)*
Wade: Thank you so much for carrying us!
Mark: Look at how much carrying Ethan did!
*Everyone laughing at Ethan's "helping"*
Mark: Is your back sore from all that?
Are you okay?!
Ethan: Whew, I did some he-eavy lifting!
Wade: Yeah, I don't know what I would've done
if Ethan wasn't carrying us!
Mark: Yeah, man, I'm--
You're sweating ain't cha?
*Cocky* Ethan: You're welcome, Wade! :DDD
Wade: At least he's had 28 deaths!
Ethan: Sorry guys, I--I gotta go
I gotta go take a shower 'cause I am
SWEATY from all that!
Wade: you can do us four against two hard bot sharks
if we're allowed to pick.
Mark: We.... I think we can
I-I can select diver...
Ethan: Sounds good.
Wade: Yeah, I think if we all select diver..
How do you do that?
Mark: If you go to private match--
Everyone on diver?
Everyone: Yup
Mark: Okay
Aaaaand, boop
Ethan: Wait-- Hold on-- Wait
Uh-- fuck, I had some things... come.. about
Mark: Woah, 'kay cancel
Ethan: Wait- What're you....?
*Everybody "Oh Ethan"ing*
Ethan: a thing popped up!
Bob: Come on
Ethan: Uh, where do I go to select--
Mark: "Private match"; "Play", "Private Match"
Mark: You-- Are you-- Okay..
Wade: Use four bars that say:
Quick Match, Match-Making, Private Match, and Tutorial
on the left side of the screen
once you click the big "Play" button on top.
Ethan: That's not here ;___;
Mark: Whaddya mean "its--
Bob: You have to go back to the Main Menu
Ethan, click "Return to menu"
Ethan: Oh wait-- No, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it
Mark: Oh wait, yeah
Mark: What're you doing?
Bob: God dammit, Jesus Christ
Ethan: No, I got it
Mark: Alright, are you diver?
Ethan: Uh
*Another one of his Ethan Giggles*
Passive Wade: Click private match,
click the  big diver picture.
Bob: GET YOUR ACNE
OUT OF YOUR EARS T_T
*Mark and Ethan laughing*
aND GO--
LEFT!
*Mark and Ethan continuing dying of laughter*
Bob: god damn... :)
ethan & mark: *laughter*
Wade: I don't want to be *inaudible* here
but, diver's actually on the right.
*More laughter*
*MORE laughter. i think they're going insane*
Mark: I'm sorry,
I'm okay.
Okay, alright, everyone's diver, right? [more laughter]
Ethan: I think so
Mark: Hey cool, it worked
Bob: Yay, it worked!
Wade: Yay...
Mark: We're gonna die aren't we?
We're gonna die.
Wade: Yeah :D
Bob: Nah, we're fine.
Mark: So, hard bots are bad. Right?
Wade: If that's like the highest difficulty,
I remember them, yeah.
Mark: Yeah, uh, I think it is.
Oh..kay.
Bob: I just wanna fuck one of them--
Ethan: This is a little less spooky...
one of those sharks.
Ethan: ... its not as dark.
Mark: You-- you're not supposed to fuck the shark.
Bob: No, yeah, we're s'posed to fuck them, right ??
Mark: No. NO.
Bob: We're supposed to fuck 'n kill 'em.
Mark: Yeah, fucking KILL 'em..
Oh not fuck AND kill 'em,
fuck𝐢𝐧𝐠 kill 'em [why are they like this]
Ethan: No, not fuck them to death..
that's not...
Wade: Screw 'em!
Bob: I mean I was like,
"how do you even do that to a shark?" but,
I guess that makes more sense
Ethan: Have you been doing that the WHOLE time?
Mark: Yeah!
Bob: Yeah
Ethan: Have you just been fucking the sharks?
Bob: That-- Is that wrong?
Mark: Ye-yeah, actually
Wade: Not if it feels right.
Mark: I mean even if it feels right--
I-- I'm-- the logistics
Bob: It doesn't really 𝐟𝐞𝐞𝐥 right,
Bob: but, I just thought that was the whole thing
we were here doing.
*EVERYONE YELLING*
Bob: Holy fucking shit!
OH MY GOD.
Ethan: JESUS CHRIST!
Mark: WOA-AAY-AY-AY
Okay! Alright!
Ethan: Don Walsh!
Mark: I'M ALIVE! :D
Ethan: murdered me.. *laughing*
Wade: Ah, WHYYYYYYYYY! D:
Mark: Oh-ho my God. :0
Ho-oly shit
Ethan: I love the name of the shark: "Don Walsh"
*Ethan laughing*
Mark: "Don Walsh"? *while laughing*
Wade: What about the other one like,
"Jacques Cousteau" or whatever?
Ethan: Look at the name of the shark!
Mark: Oh my God
Bob: Oh God, its here! Its heRE!
Oh, for fucks sake!
Ethan: WHOA :0
God damn!
Mark: Holy shIIIIIIIIt!
Okay, got one of them.
Jesus--
WO-HOAH
FACKING FUCK D:
Bob: They never fucking go away! *Wade screaming in the background*
Mark: No they do not!
Ethan: Was it Don? Was it Don that killed you?
Bob: Wuh-- Uh-- wuh..
I just spawned!
It killed me in spawn! >:[
Wade: Yeah
Mark: Woah..!
Mark: Okayyy IIII--
Mark: FUCKING FUCK
Ethan: Where are they?
Bob: Oh God-- I just spawned, and it's right there!
Ethan: Guys, I think we're a little in over our heads--
Mark: No, no, no
Just-- everybody focus,
everybody just stick together
don't go on your own.
Ethan: Okay..
We got this
Ethan: Okay
Mark: Keep dodgin'.
Dodge around.
Dodge-- AAHHHHH
FAAAAAK!
Ethan: BOB USE YOUR "FUCKING" TECHNIQUE!
Bob: OH ITS NOT DEAD!
ITS NOT DEAD!
Ethan: Oh, its dead, okay
Bob: I shot 'em!
Mark: Ay yi yi, yi
Okay..
Ethan: Bob, are you using your "fucking" technique?
Mark: I'll try to re--
Ethan: Is it working?
Mark: Yeah
Ethan: It doesn't
Bob: This is totally different,
Ethan: seem to be working
this is completely different than its been so far--
Ethan: OOH, GOD DAMMIT (x3)
Mark: So, when you were fucking 'em--
Bob: --I GOTCHA!
Oh.. no, I didn't save you, he killed you.
Calm Mark: *trying to ask his question* When you were fucking 'em before..
Wade: Why is S.T.E.V.E. so far away?!
Bob: oh, oH, OH, 𝐎𝐇
Mark: So--
Bob: Can someone kill Don Walsh
Wade: OOAHHHH, WHAT HAPPENED?
[Inaudible screaming from Wade]
Wade: OHHHHH!
Mark: WOAH!
I damaged it,
where THE FUCK DID IT GO?!
Its right in front of me-- OH MY GOD
Oh my god! (x3)
Its dead, its dead, its dead..
Wade: They already have upgraded the Great White
Bob: Huh, huh, huh, huh, huh
Mark: I don't know where you guys are,
I have lost everybody ._.
Bob: I'm by S.T.E.V.E., come to S.T.E.V.E
Ethan: I'm by S.T.E.V.E, too.
Mark: Okay.
Wade: Yeah, we're all by S.T.E.V.E.
Bob: Is anyone else actually collecting gold?
Mark: Yeah I am, I am
Bob: 'Cause I-- so far I'm not
Mark: I am
Bob: Oh, who's fucking bleeding? T_T
Mark, you're bleeding
Mark: Sorry.
Bob: Get away from me.
Ethan: Get out of here!
Mark: Heh
"Get outta here, bleeder! >:("
Ethan: Swim into the open ocean,
but don't be near us! :)
Mark: Guys, I just want a friendly hug
It'll make me feel better :')
Bob: Oh, GOD! IT'S ON ME! IT'S ON ME!
IT'S ON ME! IT'S ON ME!
Mark: See? Not 𝐦𝐲 fault. B|
Not 𝐦𝐲 fault, guys.
Ethan: Mark, if you look to your left,
you see where you can see nothing,
swim in 𝐭𝐡𝐚𝐭 direction.
Mark: No, guys, I'm fine -- *wait for it*
You guys are just-- *gets eaten right as he talks*
AAHHHHH!!! D:<
Ethan laughing.
Mark: You guys coulda killed him,
just a little bit sooner,
that woulda been great. :)
Bob: This is fine.
I'm here, I'm here.
Wade: Yeah, I'm dying.
Bob: OH, HO, HO!
I SHOT HIM IN THE FACE!
Mark: ._.
:0
WOAH, I JUST SPAWNED (x3)
OOHH MMAAII GOODD
Ethan: Its so hard to get them!
They're so fast!
Mark: Ow :(
Wade: *scream with blank expression*
Mark: Woah.
Wade: Oh. Oh :o Oh?
I'm a professional :D
Bob: Good shit, Wade.
Mark: You did it, Wade.
We believed in you the whole time.
Wade: I'm bleeding so badly D,:
Mark: Okay, get the fuck outta here, Wade.
Mark: I'm gonna die (x3)
Wade: I must repair S.T.E.V.E.
Bob: I'm gonna heal S.T.E.V.E. a little bit
Mark: Woah, God that was *SO* close
Ow-ee, ow-ee D':
Bob: Oh, It's comin', it's comin''
Mark: ow-eee *heheh*
Ethan: Oh D: Oh!
I got him,
don't worry.
oOoH, that hurt
Mark: we gotta stick together
Ethan: OH, FUCK, god dammit
Bob: I shot him (x3)
*Bob noises of worry*
Mark: We gotta stick together :/
Wade: I am out of ammo..
at least I have this sword! :D
Ethan: Oh
Okay, I'm wounded a lil bit
Bob: You gotta find ammo, Wade.
There's ammo boxes around.
Ethan: Oh~ D:
Wade: There's health, too.
Ethan: Hello~?
I'm just swimming and bleeding in the oh o--
--PEN OCEAN
Bob: I heard the shark,  I HEARD THE SHARK NEAR ME!
Bob: NEAR ME! (x4)
Mark: Oh, fuck there was the other one!
Bob: I stabbed it to death!
Oh God, they're both by me!
Mark: Where'd it go? (x3)
I need it.
Bob: It's over here! I blasted it!
Mark: Woah.
Bob: OH! You dead bitch! >:D
Mark: Oh, we have the same gun. That's awesome.
Mark: Okay, alright, okay, alright, okay...
I'm gonna back into a corner,.
It's probably the best strategy right now.
Ethan: Oh~..
Where are they?
Mark: ♫ where are they? ♫
♫ I'm so scared now ♫ D:
Ethan: ♫ I'm so scared ♫
Bob: They're not at this main door,
I'm watching it.
Ethan: There's a bunch 'a treasure up here
Bob: Got my night-vision scope on;
I'm watchin' it.
Bob: They're comin' in. They're comin' in.
Front door, front door.
Mark: I see him, I see him, I see him.
Bob: Gotcha, bitch! Gotcha, bitch! :D
Mark: Oh!
Mark: Where's the other one? Where's the other one?
Bob: Oh the other one's inside-- inside-- INSIDE.
Mark: Alright, its dead (x4)
Ethan: Got him
I'm sniping from above
Mark: Good, good, good, good.
That's good. That's good.
We're doin' great.
Bob: I'm gonna keep watching out here, with my night vision.
Mark: I got my 10-spear gun.
Ethan: OH! God dammit! THEY'RE HERE!
BOB: THEY'RE COMIN' (x2) ABOVE (x3)
Mark: Ohh, God.
Mark: I SEE HIM.
Bob: I HIT HIM.
HIT HIM AGAIN. HIT HIM AGAIN.
Mark: AHH! Awww, FUCK! D:<
Bob: I'M ALIVE!
Wade: OHH NOOO. *screams of terror*
Mark: Oh, that didn't go as planned.
Bob: Oh, I hit him! I hit him!
Awh, fUCk.
Aww, fuck!
Bob: Oh, God--
Mark: Oh, hang on.
Bob: That shark's gotta be low! I hit him.
Mark: --it's gotta be-- I killed him-- Okay.
Bob: I had shooted him.
Mark: You did. I saw. it was goo-d.
Wade: --you've got tons of lives left.
Ethan: Uh-huh...
Mark: Woah-- Fucking hell!
Ethan: Oh! No..! D,:
Well, theres's one down.
Mark: Ho, shit.
Why doesn't this volley gun kill him in one go?
It seems like--
Wade: AHH! HELP, HELP!
Mark: H-- oh--I-- Di-- Oh, fuck
Bob: Oh God, oh fuck.
Ethan: god dammit!
Mark: We're in--
Bob: OUTSIDE (x8)
Mark: Okay, okay, we're good, we're good.
Okay, we got no lives left. That's--
Bob: *panicking* OUTSIDE (x4)
Mark: Woah! Fucking
Oh boy.
That's not.. good.
Okay.
Bob: He just attacked my dead body.
Oh no, that was you.
I'm just watching you.
Mark: Oh no-- Wade, Its just us
Ethan: I'm done. I can't re-spawn anymore
Mark: AAHHHH!
Mark: FFFFFUCK!
Wade: NO!
[all yelling] Mark & Ethan: WADE, IT'S ALL ON YOU!
Mark: Wade, go!
Ethan: Wade, you're still alive!
Bob: Oh my god.
Wade, you can do it.
Ethan: We can still win this. >:0
Mark: ...you got it.
Mark: Only one more stop,
and then.. the walk back.
Wade:Nooooooooooo! [Everybody's "Ohhh"s and "Lol"s]
Bob: Jesus Christ...
Mark: Oh, fuck
Ethan: WELL!
Mark: WOW!
Ethan: The sharks won by a lot!
Mark: Well, Ethan!
[Ethan laughs]
Oh my god--
Ethan: I-- I carried us guys! :D
twice? In *ONE* day?
How--
Ethan: Yeah we--we're, uh..
we-we're almost there because of *ME*,
but, Wade, and Bob, and Mark,
*YOU* guys fucked it all up :D
Mark: Wade really fucked it up at the end there,
like, we were all watching.
No one has the assists, that you do..
Ethan.
NO ONE.
*laughter* Wade: Nobody had the spray that you had!
Not a one *laughing*
[Mark's awesome outro music: Crazy La Paint]